It's no secret that movie stars can make millions
upon millions of dollars to play someone else
on screen.
But for some actors, money isn't everything—particularly
when it comes to sequels.
Find out why certain household names decided
not to follow up a successful film, despite
being offered a truckload of money.
Vin Diesel
Fast & Furious movies come out at a rate that's,
well, fast and furious.
Vin Diesel was in the first film, and all
the most recent entries, but he skipped the
2003 sequel 2 Fast 2 Furious, despite being
offered 25 million dollars.
Diesel told Hashtag Legend:
"Sequels had gotten such a bad name and I
had started to think of that first Fast and
Furious as a classic, like a Rebel Without
a Cause.
If we 'sequelised' it the way studios were
doing at the time, just slapping a story together,
I'd ruin the chance of that first one becoming
a classic."
Ironically, Diesel used that time to film
The Chronicles of Riddick, a sequel to the
2000 movie Pitch Black.
That franchise was much closer to Diesel's
heart, so much so that he took home a relatively
meager $50,000 dollars.
Will Smith
With The Fresh Prince of Bel-Air, Will Smith
transitioned from music into television.
And with Independence Day, the top grossing
movie of 1996, Smith transitioned from TV
star to full-fledged movie star.
"Who's the man, huh?
Who's the man?"
When producers approached Smith to return
for an Independence Day sequel, Smith countered
their initial offer with a request for $50
million dollars for two sequels.
Despite getting shot down, Smith still considered
being in the movie.
In 2015, the sequel's director, Roland Emmerich,
said:
"He just was tired of sequels and he did another
science fiction film, which was his father-son
story, so he opted out."
Michael Keaton
Primarily known as a comedic actor, Michael
Keaton was a bit of a left-field choice to
star in Tim Burton's Batman films.
But both Batman and Batman Returns ended up
doing incredibly well.
That's why it was so shocking when Keaton
walked away from the franchise before Batman
Forever went into production.
He also walked away from a reported $15 million
dollars.
"What was it about three that you just didn't
like?"
"Sucked."
"Yeah?
There you go!
That pretty much says it all."
"Yeah, it just was awful."
Jodie Foster
Movies that win the Academy Award for Best
Picture don't often have sequels, but The
Silence of the Lambs isn't like most movies.
"Most serial killers keep some sort of trophies
from their victims."
"I didn't."
"No.
No, you ate yours."
After winning an Oscar for her portrayal of
FBI agent Clarice Starling, Jodie Foster was
offered $20 million dollars to return for
the sequel---one of the biggest actor paychecks
up to that time.
But Foster said no, deciding instead to direct
a film about a circus sideshow performer called
Flora Plum.
The film died in production, and Julianne
Moore stepped into the role of Clarice, for
which she was paid a mere $2 million dollars.
Keanu Reeves
The original Speed was lightning in a bottle.
A huge box office success, it made veteran
actor Keanu Reeves a viable action star, and
thrust Sandra Bullock onto the A-list.
Then there's Speed 2: Cruise Control, which
ranks among the most poorly-reviewed, franchise-killing
sequels of all time.
Bullock returned, but Reeves didn't, reportedly
leaving $11 million dollars on the table.
After filming the physically taxing Chain
Reaction, Reeves' manager had a simple explanation:
"He didn't want to do two action movies back-to-back."
Bruce Willis
In the first two films in The Expendables
franchise, Bruce Willis appeared alongside
an ensemble of faded-but-beloved action stars.
To return for the third film, he was offered
$3 million dollars—for just four days of
work.
But when Willis asked for a salary boost to
$4 million, it turns out he was, well, expendable.
Producers refused the pay increase and Harrison
Ford got the part instead.
The Expendables 3 co-star and co-writer Sylvester
Stallone tweeted out that Willis' behavior
was: "Greedy and lazy...a sure formula for
career failure."
Katie Holmes
Dawson's Creek actress Katie Holmes starred
as Bruce Wayne's girlfriend in Batman Begins.
But she opted out of the next movie, The Dark
Knight, choosing instead to film the forgettable
heist comedy Mad Money.
Holmes told Business Insider in 2016 that
she doesn't regret her choice to walk away
from a critically-acclaimed blockbuster, saying,
"It was a decision that I made at that time
and it was right for me at that moment."
According to The Wall Street Journal, Holmes
would've earned between $1 and 2 million dollars
for The Dark Knight, much more than the roughly
$250,000 she got for Mad Money.
Jim Carrey
1994 was the year Jim Carrey officially became
a household name, when he starred in three
hit movies: Ace Ventura: Pet Detective, The
Mask, and Dumb and Dumber.
Carrey starred in sequels to Ace Ventura and
Dumb and Dumber, but turned down the sequel
to The Mask, despite a $10 million dollar
offer.
On turning down that much cash, Carrey told
the Los Angeles Times:
"I don't want people to start thinking about
me as, like, a money person, cause I'm not.
To me, that's a little Monopoly game that's
being played in the other room."
"That's how wealthy people laugh…
OH!"
Hilary Duff
If you weren't a tween or the parent of a
tween in the early 2000s, then the Lizzie
McGuire television phenomenon probably escaped
you.
Disney executive Dick Cook was so confident
that a Lizzie McGuire movie would be a hit
that he offered lead actress Hilary Duff a
two-movie deal for $3.5 million dollars.
Hilary's manager, who happened to be her mother,
asked for $5 million instead.
Cook said $4 million was his final offer and
gave the Duffs a deadline when the offer would
expire.
A day after that deadline, Duff's mom agreed
to the $4 million, but it was too late.
And that's why there's only one Lizzie McGuire
movie.
Will Ferrell
Elf is a modern-day Christmas classic, and
to revisit Buddy the Elf would be to ruin
the spirit of the original.
That's a big reason why Will Ferrell refused
to make Elf 2, resisting the lure of offers
as high as $29 million dollars.
Regarding his decision, he told The Guardian:
"I remember asking myself: could I withstand
the criticism when it's bad and they say,
'He did the sequel for the money'?
I decided I wouldn't be able to.
I didn't want to wander into an area that
could erase all the good work I've done."
"So I'm here now, I found you, daddy."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!